et on va rester à kiev justement la
capitale ukrainienne nous attend notre
invité bonjour romain goupil
vous êtes réalisateur je lisais vous
êtes à kiev donc pour tourner un
document notamment on vient d'entendre
avec notre correspondante notre envoyé
spécial l'état de la capitale
ukrainienne une sorte de calme relatif
c'est ce que vous avez pu constater vous
aussi
on est tous ce rôle et même
à l'état comme si l'autre le temps le
temps était suspendu une espèce des
tranchées c'est rémy ourdan le
correspondant du monde qu'il l'écrivaine
étrange normalité c'est-à-dire que ça
continue à faire des courses il ya
l'électricité
et il ya de l'eau et on a en entend tous
ces sirènes on en entend tous ceux des
télés de ces bruits d'artillerie temps
en temps
malheureusement un immeuble plus proche
7 km 15 km est touché par un tir on sait
pas si c'est des tirs d'intimidation 6
et des erreurs non sens capable
à l'offensive générale tant redoutée
c'est signe que la résistance parce que
quand vous entendez les bruits vous
entendez deux types de oui et c'est
impossible à déterminer comme ça mais il
ya deux types de bruits il ya ceux qui
essayent d'écrabouiller les villages
autour et de s'approcher et c'est la
résistance et l'armée prenne yen qui
répond c'est pas dans le même sens c'est
à dire que du coup les sens sont
différents et on en entend on a entendu
toute cette nuit et c'est ça fait
plusieurs jours qui a une résistance
acharnée et c'est le plat la principale
information c'est que le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que ça se passe pas
exactement comme le rêvait
l'état major de cette opération
militaire spéciale qu'est une opération
de criminels qui consistent simplement
essayer d'écrabouiller de faire peur
d'impressionner en envoyant même ce
missile où ils ont fait une pub
incroyable en disant en voix et en a
envoyé une
super missiles à 12 km 12 km pourquoi
pour toucher un dépôt d'armes et en
maniement
de la roumanie mais ils l'ont fait
savoir de même qu'ils ont fait savoir
écouter il a bien souvent répété je suis
capable d'utiliser l'armé nucléaire je
serais éventuellement s'il ya des armes
chimiques
en fait il a fait une antiphrase
laissant entend qu'il avait les
capacités de répondre il y arriver un
système de terreur romain goupil
justement vous vous étiez également à
sarajevo en 1993 pendant le siège vous
avez donc pu assister au siège de cette
ville et ce que alors c'est peut-être un
peu excessif de le dire mais ce que vous
voyez des similitudes dans la manière
dont se déroule cette guerre autour de
kiev est ce que vous avez pu voir vous à
sarajevo est ce que d'une scène une
certaine manière on peut voir des
similitudes selon
énormément dans le dans les buts de
guerre ça veut dire deux des criminels
comme été pelos évite tout comme les
poutine qui sont organisées dans leurs
terres et sur un système
communiste bolchévique kg 10 steaks
avait d'ailleurs pas tout ce que vous
voulez qu'est devenir la fin justifie
les moyens tous les moyens pour obtenir
la grande servi effet caminos et rich
dans tout est possible et plus ration
unique l'assassinât de décapiter unis
vielles viol et terroriser les
populations ayant certes et ça allait
trop et là contre exactement le même
type de raisonnement au nom de encore
plus dément c'est à dire que ils ont
suivi crêpés on a été humilié en
tressant 49 par la bataille des merles
quand on a perdu contre les ottomans il
faut qu'on recommence encore face la
grande serbie là c'est la folie absolue
par du 7e siècle et que kiev serait le
père en
russie
on ça se passe
corrigé le ciel ici on est tous inquiets
d'une opération qu'il grossit nunes six
réalisations du conflit c'est à dire
allez hop
s'il est prêt à tout si la fin justifie
tous les moyens eh ben les moyens ça
peut être notre frein merci beaucoup
romain goupil d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je suis désolé nous sommes un
peu pris par le temps et la connexion
est malheureusement capricieuse encore